we need some ID for them to make sure
that he's legit I know I'm idea here
[Music]
outside of knowing that everyone has
forever called me Doogie Howser I had no
idea who Doogie Howser was I didn't know
how it was even spelled I'm excited to
watch shows let's flick it on is that
everybody ready to say it like you know
let's turn around there's been an
accident just over here what are you
doing the car stop it what is easy in
proper City you're going to audit
something very excessive please do we
slow down return to the vehicle you know
you'll be going to jail for criminal
negligence this man has a dislocated
fracture of the femur and he's gonna
lose his leg unless I fix it right away
now hold his torso down rotate his leg
what the hell you chose behind the knee
he'll lose just like the gangrene moving
this just hold it down ha ha I kill you
I've never watched this looks like he's
had some sort of motorcycle accident or
bicycle accident but he's saying there's
a fracture of the femur which is the big
thigh bone which is a very very strong
bone by the way stronger than cement
he's saying that it's fractured but then
also dislocated which in correct
terminology u.s. a displaced fracture
which means that the bones don't connect
and sometimes when there's when there's
a displaced fracture like that it can
put pressure on arteries therefore cut
off circulation very dangerous not
because of gangrene though gangrene is
when you get an infection from a lack of
circulation in this case what the danger
would be is that the the leg would lose
circulation and necrosis from a lack of
oxygenation not from infection so what
he's doing is right in the sense but for
the wrong reasons at least he explained
the wrong reasons you ready
okay okay we're getting to a circulation
but they'll love that the jeans are
still on and yet here you know is that
he's getting some circulation Doogie
you're better than that
who is this kid that's my son the doctor
Wizkid breezed through high school in
nine weeks that's a little extra
Princeton graduates ten-year-old prodigy
14 year old passes Medical Board kid
doctor can't buy beer can prescribe
drugs kid doctor delivers baby and
shopping mom sexiest doctor saves life
on plain kid doctor delivers baby and
shopping well it's pretty funny on the
similarities and look I get this is the
TV show that's supposed to be funny and
all that here's why this would never
happen you may know a lot of information
but your judgment and your development
of your judgment doesn't happen till a
little bit later in life because of your
neurological development aka your brain
this child may know everything there is
to know about medicine probably more
than most other doctors but that
judgment factored that really comes with
experience william johnson black male
julian with cardiomyopathy and failure
we did a chest x-ray EKG and an
echocardiogram he has a murmur of mitral
insufficiency I gave him to Jackson
point one two five milligrams lasix 20
milligrams PID and out Dokdo twelve
point five milligrams bandy also I'd
like to send him to nuclear medicine for
a cardiac scan at 9:30 thank you dr.
house that was actually a very
legitimate presentation of someone who's
suffering with cardiomyopathy when the
heart gets overwhelmed there's a wide
variety of conditions of why the heart
can go get overwhelmed you can develop a
condition those congestive heart failure
where the heart just literally doesn't
pump blood effectively in that case you
get a buildup of fluid around the lungs
and the lower extremities and you need
to take medications that will help you
get rid of that excess fluid now the
biggest way to control this at least
what we do in our offices outside of
medications is lifestyle changes with
one of the most important being
decreasing sodium intake for these
patients in fact one of the leading
causes of patients to be readmitted into
the hospital for a congestive heart
failure exacerbation is eating takeout
because it's so high in sodium it's not
crazy I always have water gun fights
with my patients Oh William you're not
feeling too well are you not to worry
young man we're gonna make you feel much
better
we might even give you a new heart what
do you say to that
hey no way forget that we're gonna fix
you up so we can get a really sick kid
in here his renal functions decreased
his creatinine is elevated he can't
survive a transplant supporting these
test results most certainly can the
boy's mother's already given her consent
on your recommendation but statistically
he's got a better chance if we just
repair the valve basically what they're
arguing about is the steps on which to
take to fix the young boy's heart
the reason the young boy's heart is in
cardiac failure is because he has an
impaired valve this is the valve that
sits in between the chambers of the
heart the atrium and the ventricle when
the heart pumps it opens and then when
the heart relaxes it closes to make sure
that the blood doesn't always pool at
the bottom of the heart now if this
valve is now working properly it can put
a lot of strain on different parts of
the heart therefore making the heart
essentially function at a much lower
rate which is deadly for this child
because his heart isn't pumping blood
effectively it's affecting his kidneys
his kidneys aren't getting enough blood
and therefore are slowly failing one of
the most important factors in deciding
whether or not to operate on somebody is
their chance of having side effects from
surgery which means decrease blood flow
possible chance of infection renal
failure Doogie Howser's right in this
case at least in my mind the child is a
very high-risk patient and it's better
to repair the valve first and then go
ahead with the possible heart transplant
later on you're gonna kill him you don't
give a crap dr. Hauser you will behave
don't talk to me like you're my father
you're not September 21st
oh my god I wasn't even born yet when
Doogie Howser a16 I wasn't born are you
ready for this Jenny and Stuart dibs
get out sex tomorrow night oh yeah you
said the same thing about Suzy Berluti
last year Angie Berluti was in the bag
fine puked on a shoe it would have
happened sure penny hey you're just
jealous pencil-neck cuz I'm gonna get
sex and you never even kissed a girl
I've kissed plenty name one oh yeah
right I'm gonna do it during a slow
dance it's all figured out tell her
girls love getting sniffed I doubt that
very much
I come in here an emergency expecting a
qualified physician and I get a 16 year
old kid that's negligence pure and
simple you'll be holding still for a big
fat lawsuit in a federal court
16 years old I'll let it count for
infliction of emotional distress well
I'm sorry you feel this way sir but as
an attorney you must know there's no
duty owed by the hospital with respect
to the age of its doctors nor is there
an approximate cause connecting me to
the harm suffered and even if you could
make out a prima facie case of
negligence you don't have diversity
jurisdiction to get this into federal
court why am I getting a 16 year old
maybe let him perform the procedure
first or not perform the procedure and
threaten to sue in the middle of the
procedure not making much sense there
pal I like younger men Doogie I always
have it's here man though on a few
occasions I've caught you know admiring
me
you should probably get back to the ER
and that was just one given our mutual
attraction towards each other and given
the fact that we probably function
better professionally
if those attractions were extinguished
it might make sense for our respective
fantasies to be huh Judy monster
whoa
this is aggressive for 16 year old happy
birthday dude that made no sense she
takes off his pants and says happy
birthday and all these people appear
while he's pantsless I need an
explanation for this it's only a joke
hey forget it it's just that you're such
a good doctor we sometimes forget you're
only 16 years old
now there's the worst line ever they
would have done that to a 21 year old
doctor or a 30 year old dog you take off
his pants what's going on in this
hospital no toe tag that's great I don't
know how so many bodies get in
[Applause]
whoa that was a weird handshake what was
that that was weird
I'm scared don't be good new hearts
gonna be so prized babies never make it
are you kidding no way I guess it not
gonna lie he's pretty good with the
bedside manner for being 16 years old
he's empathetic he lets the patient
voice their concerns responds adequately
to the concerns is very reassuring sniff
is working
the sniff is working
[Music]
what don't do it do it Dukey don't do it
so creepy no but apparently works a
little Doogie oh no oh no what happened
he was asleep in his bed when he
suddenly started defibrillate that means
the heart is like pumping like this
where it's not efficient and not enough
blood is leaving the heart essentially
it's the patients and CodeBlue and
they're in cardiac arrest I'm sorry dr.
Howser I guess there was just nothing
either what I was losing a patient is
really hard whether or not you're 16
years old or 36 years old never really
changes it's always difficult especially
if you've made a decision that that
affected the patient in a negative way
it's gonna be a lot to deal with as he
continues in his medical career being so
young and inexperienced first time I
lost a young patient I cried like a baby
as you get older you learn to handle I
don't want to handle it if you're gonna
be a doctor you'll have to crying when
you have a negative patient outcome is
totally appropriate and as we've gotten
more information on the matter and I've
done the research and looked into this
we find that patients actually
appreciate seeing doctors emotional
reactions to these situations so that if
you're gonna cry with a patient that's
good many times 20 30 years ago doctors
would try to hide this go in another
room because they viewed themselves as
unprofessional if they showed their
emotions but sharing an emotional moment
with a patient or the patient's family
is actually quite beneficial in healing
to everyone involved
[Music]
as a doctor there's no bigger moment in
your life than when you lose your first
patient as a young boy kissing your
first partner is also one of the biggest
moments in your life so for him to go
through both in the same day and he just
got his driver's license it must be
quite emotional for him to say the least
that's like the biggest factor of this
show and I know I'm reviewing the show
it's supposed to be part funny in part
serious that's what would stop a
preclude a young person from becoming a
doctor so early that emotional maturity
the ability to be disciplined that when
someone tells you something and they're
being unfair to be able to deal with it
to have a proper level of empathy and
communication so I don't foresee how
true Doogie Howser coming anytime soon
but I will be excited to watch more of
the show if you enjoyed Duque Howser
definitely check out this video it's a
total blast as always stay happy and
healthy
let's do dance
[Music]